la douleur c'est complexe tu es à la
fois une histoire de perception et de
sensation la perception c'est le signal
électrique c'est le message qui est
transmis à notre cerveau par les
neurones quand ils sont stimulés par un
truc qui fait mal et la sensation c'est
l'analyse que notre cerveau fait de ce
message donc si je vous dis que la
douleur c'est un stimulus un truc qui
coupe qui pique qui brûle etc qui excite
déterminaison nerveuse de neurones
spécialisés dans la douleur qu'on
appelle nocycepteurs et il réagissent
soit quand il détecte une agression
mécanique c'est-à-dire une déformation
de la peau un choc une pénétration
d'objets etc soit les trucs thermiques
les trucs très chauds ou les trucs très
froids et ils peuvent réagir aussi quand
ils détecte la présence de certaines
substances chimiques que ces neurones
transmettent ensuite le message
électrique jusqu'à la moelle épinière
d'abord il va déclencher un réflexe
qu'on appelle un réflexe de sauvegarde
en gros qui va servir à faire stopper le
stimulus douloureux genre en retirant sa
main de la plaque de cuisson par exemple
et le cerveau va l'analyser à peu près
de la façon suivante